الصراع على مقعد الرئاسه في الولايات
المتحده يشتعل مبكرا راويه فمن المرجح ان
تتزاحم اسماء كثيره على الترشح لهذا
المنصب الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد
ترامب اول مترشحين رسميا للرئاسيات سيتعرف
قريبا على اول منافسه الرسميين الامر
يتعلق بالنكهه لاسفير السابقه للامم
المتحده وحكمه ولايه كارولاين الجنوبيه
التي تخطط للاعلان عن ترشحها لتكون بذلك
اول منافس جمهوري معلن لترامب نقلا عن
صحيفه واشنطن الصحيفه كشفت ايضا
عن ترشحها بطريقه لافته للانظار من خلال
مقطع فيديو وذلك رغبه منها في زياده
الحماس حول هذا الحدث وبحسب الاخبار
الوارده فان هي اللي اختارت مدينه
تشارليستن بي كارولين الجنوبيه للاعلان عن
الترشح على ان يتم ذلك في منتصف الشهر
الجاري
ترشح هيلي ينظر من الان بصراع محتدم بين
الجمهوريين لسيامه وان ترامب الذي كان
يتوقع ان تكون طريقه نحو الترشح مفروشه
سيجد امامه منافسين اخرين منهم من يتوفر
على حظوظ قائمه ياتي في طليعه هذه الاسماء
جندي سانتس حاكم ولايه فلوريدا الذي
ارتفعت شعبيته بشكل كبير بين الجمهوريين
في جميع انحاء الولاده خلال العامين ونصف
العامه الماضي كما بات يوصف داخل الاوساط
السياسيه بالوجه الجديد للحزب الجمهوري بل
ومستقبل الاسم الاخر قد يكون منافسا
محتملا لترامب وهو وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
السابق مايك بومبي الذي لم يستبعد
امكانيات ترشحه ويملك بومباي وخبره كبيره
بعدما كان شغل حقيبتين مهمتين وهما وزاره
الخارجيه اضافه الى تراسه وكاله المخابرات
المركزيه الامريكيه بطبيعه الحال
هذا ولا يزال ترامب وديسانتس المرشحين
البارزين
والرئيسيين حتى الان وقد يواجه ترامب
تحديا حقيقيا من حاكم فلوريدا بعدما احتل
الاخير المرتبه الاولى في استطلاعات
الترشح للمره الثانيه على التوالي في اقل
من شهرين